the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
in this video i will show you what
happens in my own version of game of
thrones season 9. as i'm sure most of
you know by now i have been writing my
own season of game of thrones this is
what i think hbo should have done if
they decided to make another season of
the show i basically started making
these videos because i know a lot of us
were left unsatisfied with how game of
thrones ended so i began my season right
where hbo left off at the end of their
8th season i have made 8 of my own
episodes so far i would recommend
watching all of those first before you
start watching this video otherwise you
will not fully understand what's
happening in this episode you will see
what happens during what will most
likely be the very last battle in
westeros this is season 9 episode 9
which i am naming the final chapter
shall we begin
in the opening scene of this episode we
will see a massive army marching along
the king's road all of their footsteps
sound like the beating of a drum
there are thousands of soldiers made up
of the different armies throughout
westeros and even essos the soldiers of
the north are marching at the front of
the line as they are being led by jon
snow ghost helen reed giant spain
brienne sir podrick sir davos lorterion
and samwell right behind them are the
bannermen of house baratheon led by
gendry baratheon and arya stark
following right behind them are what
remains of the unsullied army as always
they are led by grey worm and right
behind them are the 1 000 slave soldiers
from the fiery hand who are led by
kinvara and makaro at the back of the
formation we can see there are about a
dozen small boats being held by some of
those slave soldiers each of those small
boats might be able to hold about 30 men
the sun is shining down on all of them
but not for long as the sun is resting
high in the sky it is suddenly smothered
by a massive black shadow when drogon
fully extends his enormous black wings
in front of it his dragon scales are
glistening as he soaks up the sunlight
right on the back of drogon is daenerys
who leans over on her side when the
dragon makes a hard left off the king's
road as they begin heading for a large
castle that is sitting off in the
distance the thousands of men below make
a left as well we go back to the front
of the army where jon snow and helen
reed are riding on horseback the large
item that was on helen reed's back is
now slung over the side of his horse
it's actually bouncing off the horse's
leg after every step it makes this is
when jon snow will ask helen reed what
he has been hiding under that blanket
helen reed flashes a faint smile before
he says you will see soon enough jon
snow it is a gift that i have brought
for you john doesn't know whether to be
happy about this or not i'm not sure if
i like the sound of that says john who
shows a thin smile as well right over
jon's shoulder we can see samwell on his
horse making his way to the front of the
line he rides up beside john and helen
reed right as jon begins asking him
something else john looks back over at
lord halen then says how many of us do
you think will actually make it out of
this alive do you really think we will
be able to save bran helen reed doesn't
answer him right away he looks into the
sky and drogon and dany flying off in
the distance when he looks back at jon
he says well it's as i've said before
what will you be willing to sacrifice
jon snow now as for your brother bran i
will not make any assurances that you
will get him out of here alive but that
doesn't mean you can't help save
everyone else i know you want your
brother back believe me i do but you
also must remember his life isn't the
only one at stake jon silently looks
away he looks in front of him at the
castle that grows larger with each step
they make he watches as drogon and
daenerys fly in a circle above the
castle it's five long fingers reaching
into the sky finally john looks back at
helen reed and says what was your
sacrifice my lord when i met you out
beyond the wall you once said you made
the greatest sacrifice of all what did
you mean by that there is another long
silence before anything is said helen
reed looks in john's eyes and says my
own flesh and blood i sacrifice my very
own son jon snow
this new revelation stuns jon but before
he can follow up on what he said samwell
rides up alongside them with a letter in
hand i was hoping i could have a moment
with you before the battle begins says
samwell this was sent from the citadel
before you arrived in king's landing i
wasn't sure what to make of it at first
but i have a feeling you will know what
it means soon enough here i want you to
have it sam reaches out and hands john
the letter before falling back into
formation john's eyes open up a little
wider as he unfolds the letter there is
an image in the center with a few words
written above it the only thing john
focuses on is the drawing of what looks
like the face of a weirwood he studies
it for a few moments when jon begins
folding the letter we will see that this
werewolf's face is surrounded by fire
lord helen reed says we're here when jon
finally looks back up he sees an island
surrounded by a large blue lake
jon snow helen reed samwell davos
brienne and all the others begin hopping
off of their horses
arya gendry and lore tyrion lannister
walk up behind them everyone stands near
the edge of the water as they look out
across the lake at the sacred isle of
faces it doesn't look like anyone is
here says gendry it will not remain that
way says helen reed not when night falls
jon is resting his hand on the hilt of
his sword when he says then we better
get everyone over there before that
happens have the men start dropping the
boats in the water the sun will be
setting soon drogon and daenerys are
still flying above harrenhal they drop
down over the god's eye but when
daenerys looks down onto the island
she's not able to see anything through
all of the heavy brush having a bird's
eye view isn't really helping them at
least not yet it doesn't look like there
is anyone on the isle of faces from up
above either when daenerys sees them
dropping the boats into the water she
lands her dragon on the shore of the
lake we don't have enough boats for
everyone so make sure they are sent back
across until we get all of our men over
there on the island says jon one of the
northmen nods his head before stepping
into one of the small boats himself
helen reed grabs the large item from his
horse then he slings it back over his
shoulder lord tyrion lannister walks
over by sir podrick who is helping
berean with her armor he greets them
with a thin smile before he looks at sir
podrick and says i have something i want
to give you when he looks at brienne she
nods her head freeing him of his duty he
then follows lorterion who walks around
the other side of his horse he watches
him with uncertainty unsure of what this
is all about after another moment lord
tyrion emerges from behind the horse and
in his hands he is holding a sword when
he stands before him he says this was my
brother jaime's sword it's no good in my
hands i'm not sure if you will need it
but i can't think of a better mane alive
that should have it my lord this is
valyrian steel says sir podrick it is
says lorterion it was made from house
stark's ancestral valyrian steel sword
brienne has one half and now you have
the other here he reaches out and grabs
the sword from his hands when he holds
it out in front of him the fading sun
glimmers off the ripples in the blade
thank you my lord says sir podrick lord
tyrion smiles then he walks away we then
see daenerys loading grey worm and the
unsolid men on the back of her dragon
the small boats are making their way
back across now jon motions for samwell
and davos they follow him as he signals
for lorterion as well jon says i want
you three to stay over here now i don't
mean to offend any of you but if we
don't succeed without you i don't think
three extra men will make that much of a
difference i'm hoping we are back before
sunrise
jon then abruptly walks away ghost
follows right behind him he stops one of
his northmen as he makes his way back
near the shore jon says make sure you
unload the wagon full of dragonglass now
there is more than enough to fill one of
these boats on its own
jon had hundreds if not thousands of
dragonglass weapons brought down from
winterfell
they were what was left over from the
long night battle against the night king
the northman bows his head before
walking away jon's eye suddenly look for
the sky as he hears the sound of a
hundred screaming ravens from above the
isle of faces it is a dreadful sound
that reminds him of why he is here
kinvara and makaro fallen next to jon as
he walks alongside the lake can vara's
glowing red eyes find jon's she says
your brother will be waiting for you jon
snow but he is no longer the man that
you think he is the werewolves have
corrupted his mind only the purest death
will cleanse his soul now
anger flashes inside jon's eyes he grabs
kenvara by the throat but he lets go
immediately after her red ruby burns his
hand why would you say that jon says
angrily we are sorry jon snow but this
night will be dark and full of terror
says kinvara only the fire will burn
them all away now
jon runs over to the shore then signals
for everyone to get inside the boats he
looks at helen reed then yells we must
leave now lord howland reed jumps in the
boat then gives them a shove off the
shore when jon looks back he sees
kinvara standing there staring at him
her bright red ruby glowing all the
while the rest of the dozen or so boats
are filled with the slave soldiers
overlore the ends of their weapons are
now lit up with a red and orange flame
this section of the lake almost looks as
if it's on fire the sun is now setting
there is a full moon sitting above the
god's eye on this evening as the
darkness falls the sacred isle of faces
finally starts to come alive the
shrieking sound of ravens are now heard
from the forest and the center of the
island this is followed up by the sound
of ominous screams that echo across the
silent lake
all of the soldiers that are standing in
formation on the shore of the isle of
faces begin looking at each other with a
hint of fear in their eyes the moonlit
sky is suddenly blackened as drogon and
daenerys circle around the island again
daenerys watches from above but she
still doesn't see any movement from
within the center of the forest gendry
walks over by arya then says do you feel
that feel what astoria the werewolf says
gendry do you feel them looking at you
because i do
arya looks at all the different
werewoods that surround the isle of
faces all of them are looking back at
them with hatred in their eyes the faces
look nothing like the face on the
werewood back at arya's home of
winterfell arya knows she is not welcome
here but she moves forward anyway all of
the 1 000 slave soldiers of relore have
finally arrived on the island they begin
standing in formation waiting for the
signal grey worm as well as his unsolid
men are lined up beside them all of
gendry's bannermen and the men of the
north are now here also only a few of
them remain on the last of the boats
with jon snow and helen reed who are
landing ashore now when jon ghost and
lord helen reed jump out they grab their
boat and drag it up onto the beach they
walk around all of the soldiers to the
front of the formation as they watch the
final boat land on the shore as soon as
kanvara and makaro step foot on the isle
of faces a massive shadow falls from the
sky before unleashing a blue fireball
onto the lake the black shadow vanishes
back into the night sky as the entire
lake goes up in blue flames everyone
who's standing on the shore of this
sacred island is left feeling stunned by
how fast this happened daenerys looks up
into the sky thinking whatever it was
dropped down from above her jon looks
over at kinvara with a sudden rage he
thinks that she has somehow done this
since it happened right after she
stepped off the boat makaro notices this
so he walks over to jon and sets his
large hand on his shoulder then says it
has begun jon snow there is no escaping
this now they don't want us leaving here
alive the isle of faces is now
surrounded by a massive blue ring of
fire the reflection of the flames are
seen in the blood-red eyes of ghost the
white direwolf begins looking into all
of the eyes of the werewoods in front of
them we suddenly hear what sounds like
the screams of a thousand dying voices
from within the woods jon snow ghost
helen reed arya gendry grey worm as well
as everyone else begins descending on
the center of this island in search of
brandon stark black shadows begin
shifting throughout the woods all around
them while daenerys and drogon are
scanning the area from above dany
suddenly notices a massive fire start
from within the middle of the god's eye
dany does get a glimpse of small black
shadows dancing around the orange and
red flames everyone on the ground is
walking very slowly dreading what lies
ahead when jon and the others look up
they see hundreds of ravens sitting on
the branches watching them with their
white eyes as they move inward all of
them ready their weapons as they see
more and more shadows shifting around in
the woods dragonglass arrows start
raining down on them from above
dozens of soldiers begin falling down
all around them where are they yells
giant spain they're up in the trees
brian shouts back everyone suddenly
looks above them they're not able to see
who they are or exactly what they are
all they see are yellow and golden cat's
eyes glowing back at them the slave
soldiers of the fiery hand rush in the
end of their weapons are lit up on fire
with orange and red flames they hold
their weapons near the bottom of the
trees catching them all on fire the
island begins burning from within then
in an instant the little green men jump
out of the sky with their dragonglass
weapons in hand landing all around them
everyone starts hacking and slicing at
the small green men in front of them and
now behind them brianne lops off one of
their heads with her valyrian steel
sword their great big golden cat's eyes
are still glowing as their heads go
bouncing off the ground one of the green
men sticks their dragonglass spear into
the back of gendry's leg but he spins
around and slices off its head in one
swift move helen reed falls as an arrow
goes into his shoulder and back he lets
out a scream as his body hits the ground
ghost dives through the air and sinks
his razor-sharp teeth into the face of
one of the small child-like soldiers we
watch as its golden and green eyes fade
to black as its life leaves its body
when one of the little green men jumps
on tormund giant's bane's back he
reaches behind him and grabs it by its
throat he smashes its head against a
rock while screaming like a madman arya
grabs her valerian steel dagger then
jams it into the ear of one of the green
men dropping it instantly sir podrick
slices another one of them in half
before dropping another one from running
up behind buryin
daggers and swords rise and fall then
rise and fall one after another until
the forest goes silent again the little
green men were no match for thousands of
soldiers dressed in armor jon helps
helen reed get back on his feet he still
has the arrows in his back and shoulder
giant's bane walks over and yanks them
out he can still move on his own gendry
is now limping from the injury in his
leg but everyone else seems to be fine
for now all of them begin moving forward
again even slower than before after
walking only a few more feet jon and the
others begin hearing something else
shifting around in the dark woods in
front of them in the matter of moments
there are suddenly very large shadows
all around them john raises a fist
signaling for everyone to stop where
they are everyone falls silent as they
listen to the sound of leaves crunching
and branches breaking in the darkness
the slave soldiers of relore hold out
their weapons in front of them hoping to
see what's out there around them as
their flames drive away the shadows
jon's eyes have a sudden look of
disbelief when he starts to see blue
eyes faintly glowing all around him
their eyes look at the sky when they
unexpectedly hear a thunderous scream
from a dragon ring out across the island
the resurrected rhaegal drops from the
sky
daenerys is so horrified by the sight
and sound of regal she nearly falls off
drogon but she holds herself up by one
of his spikes rhaegal immediately lets
out his blue flame but drogon dives
through the sky in order to dodge it
samwell davos and loretarian are still
standing near the water on the other
side of the lake they begin running for
the castle of harrenhal when they see
rhaegal emerge in the night sky
everything lights up with red and blue
flames as the dragons unleash their fire
on each other one after another back on
the ground jon and everyone else form a
line as they see the glowing eyes move
in for the kill some of rhaegal's blue
fireballs begin striking the island
lighting up everything around them they
suddenly see what's heading their way
there are dozens and dozens of white
walkers riding on the backs of giant
elks the slave soldiers of verlor rush
in to deliver the first blow one by one
the white walkers begin snuffing out
their flaming weapons as each of the
soldiers lifeless bodies slam onto the
ground as the forest burns down all
around them daenerys can finally see
what's happening on the ground below her
from her view we can see there are
roughly 100 white walkers closing in on
everyone down below dany watches as
greyworm throws his dragonglass spear
shattering one of the white walkers and
the giant elks it was riding on the
unsolid men move in their weapons give
them a slight advantage here since the
white walkers are now high off the
ground they form a shield around
everyone standing in the center as the
white walkers rush forward they all
thrust their spears out at once
shattering several of them before they
can break their wall now when some of
the other white walkers see this they
start charging on their giant elks this
begins knocking most of the unsolid men
down as they run them over smashing some
of their skulls beneath their feet
dragonglass weapons are flying through
the air everywhere white walkers shatter
again but not all of them some of the
dragonglass misses and it unfortunately
hits a few of their own men dropping
them instantly when one of the white
walker sees jon it jumps down from the
elk with a nice sword in hand jon greets
him with his own sword in hand the white
walker swings its glowing ice sword
right at jon's head but it misses by
only inches after jon bends down to
avoid it raidus john launches back up he
brings his sword with him but this white
walker raises his own ice sword to block
it their swords smash into each other in
the air when the swords meet a
shattering sound rings out throughout
the forest the white walker's life sword
is fine it was actually jon's valyrian
steel sword that shattered you see these
white walkers are unlike the ones we
have seen before they themselves can
still die by valyrian steel and
dragonglass but their ice weapons are
much stronger than their last ones
the children of the forest at the isle
of faces made sure of that while jon is
standing there in disbelief holding
nothing but his sword's handle the white
walker brings its ice sword high above
his head moments away from delivering
his fatal blow as soon as the white
walker brings his sword down sir podrick
drives his own valyrian steel sword
through the back of this white walker's
head shattering it before it can kill
jon after only a few seconds jon finally
gathers his senses then he grabs a
dragonglass weapon from the ground
before entering the fight again this is
when the resurrected rhaegal will drop
out of the sky unleashing his blue flame
on dozens of unsolid men standing on the
ground another one of the white walkers
riding on one of the giant elks comes
rushing through the field a handful of
gendry's bannermen dive out of the way
before they get ran over kinvara
suddenly finds herself standing there
all alone before she can move the
massive elk lowers its head driving its
rack of antlers right through her body
out her back when makaro sees that
happen he lets out an agonizing scream
he immediately raises his six foot long
iron staff high above his head on the
end of his staff is a dragon's head as
he continues to let out this booming
scream the dragon's eyes begin to glow
green he suddenly swings down the staff
in a slicing motion and when he does
this the dragon's head spits out a green
flame that ignites everything in front
of it dozens of white walkers and their
elks go up in flames instantly we can
hear the sound of crackling ice as white
walkers let out a scream of their own as
they burn alive this allows jon and
everyone else to finally move forward
again most of the isle of faces is now
on fire there are red orange green and
blue flames everywhere
davos lorterion and samwell are
horrified as they watch from below the
castle of harrenhal all they're able to
see is fire from where they're at it
doesn't look like anyone will make it
out of there alive as everyone else is
moving through the woods helen reed
stops jon before they go any further
wait says helen reed there is something
you will need if you're gonna end this
tonight lord helen reed drops the large
item from his back
john has been wondering what this is as
he unfolds it from the blankets and furs
jon suddenly sees the reflection of
fires in the steel i know valerian
steele when i see it says jon where did
you get that it's name is dark's sister
it was once lord brendan rivers he gave
it to me years ago and he said i would
one day give it to you when the moment
was right you no longer have a sword of
your own i guess now is as good a time
as any
jon holds the sword firmly in his hands
then he nods his head and rushes forward
into the flames the grove of seven
werewoods is right up ahead but everyone
is suddenly stopped when another wave of
white walkers and giant elks head their
way as jon looks behind them he can see
the biggest wear what he's ever seen in
his life he fixes his eyes on the
enormous mouth at the base of it as he
looks inside he instantly notices bran
is sitting there with his eyes rolled
back in his head bran john whispers he
says the name again only louder bran
everyone looks at jon who then sticks
out his sword in brian's direction they
all see him sitting in the weirwood now
as well arya grabs her dagger with her
left hand before throwing it out in
front of her the dagger slices right
into one white walker shattering it
immediately but the dagger continues
flying through the air until it hits a
white walker right behind it shattering
that one also the fires on the floor of
the forest begin spreading all around
them mocaro raises the iron staff in the
air again shooting out another green
flame from the dragon's mouth the grove
of weirwoods in front of them begin to
go up in flames john screams out no
we must get bryan out of there however
the werewoods all around him are now
burning locking bran inside a green ring
of fire jon and arya run in to get him
but the massive flames stop them from
moving any further they run around the
circle of werewoods looking for another
opening but they don't see one
white walkers are still descending on
their location gendry grabs arya by her
shoulder he yells if we don't leave now
we will die here brienne and greyworm
are still fighting off the enemy sir
podrick is rolling around on the ground
some of his armor is melting while his
uniform is on fire it's absolute madness
on the isle of faces helen reed finds
jon again he screams jon's name before
he says get back to the shore now
daenerys needs you your brother brian is
inside that dragon you cannot save him
but maybe you can save her right as
helen reed says that a white walker
shoves his eye sword through his back
and out the front of his belly john
looks at helen reed's eyes as he drops
on his knees with blood running out of
his mouth this snaps john out of his
haze now before the white walker removes
the ice sword from helen reed's lifeless
body jon angrily shoves his own sword
into the white walker's neck after it
shatters jon runs back to where they
first landed on the island everything is
burning behind him there are red green
orange and blue flames everywhere the
dragons vanish as they fly through all
of the smoke that is right above the
isle of faces
only drogon and daenerys emerge on the
other side they do a couple circles
around the island looking for rhaegal
but they don't see him neither does john
daenerys and drogon fly back into the
black smoke again only now when they
come out the other side rhaegal is
locked onto drogon's wing the undead
dragon is biting and scratching holes
and drogon's side the dragons are now
spinning wildly out of control until
regal releases and vanishes back into
the smoke jon starts waving his sword
hoping danny notices it she lands the
dragon near him anyway when jon runs
over by her dany yells down drogon is
hurt badly jon looks at the holes in
drogon's wing then he shouts back will
he still be able to fly
i think so says danny although i don't
know how much longer jon yells out again
let me go up with you let me help you
now before danny answers she looks into
the woods where there are now white
walkers running their way get on shouts
daenerys rhaegal drops back down out of
the sky one of the white walkers grabs
his ice spear as john is climbing on
drogon's back radius john sits down
behind dany drogon lifts from the ground
the white walker throws his magical ice
weapon missing drogon only by a few feet
as the dragon soars into the sky rhaegal
dives down behind him following them
into the smoke jon yells out i need you
to get above him why shouts danny what
will you do
after a few seconds jon says i don't
know
drogon ascends further into the night
sky rising higher and higher they stay
inside of the thick black smoke for
several moments almost as if they're
hiding from regal as soon as dany sees
the resurrected dragon down below them
she has drogon dive down hundreds of
feet he slices right through the air
like a speeding bullet then as sudden as
a thunderbolt a shrieking drogon dives
onto regal locking his fangs around the
other dragon's neck the dragons were now
locked together as they begin falling
out of the sky the lake was suddenly
rushing up at them with incredible speed
as the dragons fall further and further
jon snow stands up on drogon's back with
the valyrian steel sword dark sister in
his hand within the blink of an eye jon
launches himself off drogon's back as he
is flying through the sky he raises dark
sister high above his head daenerys is
horrified as she watches this when jon
falls down onto rhaegal he drives the
valyrian steel sword through the
dragon's eye
he shoves it in with so much force the
end of the blade drives out the back of
rhaegal's throat the resurrected dragon
lets out an agonizing scream that can be
heard throughout the isle of faces
jon hangs on for dear life as the dragon
drops out of the sky half a heartbeat
later rhaegal struck the lake sending
thousands of gallons of water up into
the sky daenerys looks down and watches
as the dragon slips beneath the water
the lake boiled with dragon's blood and
then was still
daenerys immediately lands drogon on the
shore of the god's eye arya ghost
brienne and gendry come running out from
the blazing woods behind them every
single one of the werewoods are now on
fire dany screams out at arya there is
dread on her voice jon went into the
water with rhaegal says danny silence
falls over the isle of faces everyone's
fearful eyes look over at the lake
hoping jon emerges from below ghost
begins running up and down the shore
searching for jon's body the episode
will fade to black as we see air bubbles
breaking on the surface of the water
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you